[Applause]
look at them
and look how sparkly and white Madonna
got to its Madonna because I feel cooler
because she she wants it to be called
that because your show is awesome it's
such a cool idea the world according to
Jeff Goldblum and tell everybody what
the kind of premise of it is well it's
on Disney Plus and we kion where we did
they just by the way renewed us for a
second season we're gonna do a bunch
more this next year I had a great time
shooting them they are me following you
know familiar objects like flowers or or
coffee we did we did sneakers barbecues
RVs cosmetics jewelry different things
everyday things but we find the
interesting complicated surprising
things about them and then I move in and
out of the aficionados on the subject
and and have an experience but may give
way to my personal associations and a
personal epiphany or revelation of some
kind and also and also some facts about
it that may be interesting and some
abstractions and larger ideas what do
you think of that go to Texas we were in
Houston at Johnny Dangs grill Emporium
like they gave me a grill they made a
grill for me I have a grill that I
didn't wear today but I have a grill did
you post a picture of it yeah I think
there's been a picture of it oh my god I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this